full diets that include intermittent
fasting are growing in popularity google
searches for the eating plans quadrupled
in the past three years three popular
types of intermittent fasting are whole
day which means no food at all one or
two days a week
alternate day which means small meals on
specific days of the week and no
restrictions on others and time
restricted feeding which means eating
only during a four to eight hour window
each day dr. David agus is here with
what scientists say about the trend good
morning I'm exhausted just reading that
let's get to that because what
scientists saying what the data says is
what's important we hear the anecdotal
stuff but is the science backing up what
we're hearing the answer is no so I mean
it all came from some mouse experiments
where when they did intermittent fasting
they saw markers of stem cells go up and
everyone said oh my gosh if it happens
in mice I want to do it and so they try
to hack the human body and by not eating
a day a week two days a week we're
restricting your hours the bottom line
is it's no better than standard diets in
terms of losing weight it's very hard to
comply with in the clinical trials more
than 40% of people dropped out of it and
when you look at long term markers of
health it certainly doesn't add up well
my husband does is I'm gonna out him
right now and he says he feels better
and he pointed to research there are
some reports that suggest that it lowers
bad blood cells that can cause some
types of cancers oh those cells so you
got to be very careful I can give you a
lot of things that make you feel good I
can give you ice cream you say it makes
me feel good therefore I should have
lots of it and so how you feel and what
is your long-term health aren't always
the same when stress hormones go up many
times you actually feel good but it's
certainly not good for you in the long
range but it's fair to say that all fast
all of these types of fats are not
created equal I have a friend skip I
actually have a friend named skip who
does the eight hour method where he said
he only eats during an eight hour period
I agree with that and he says that it's
really worked wonders for him and he's
lost a lot of weight so are those are
some of these intermittent fasting diets
better than others that's a great point
Gail I mean not that you have a friend
named skip that the data really showed
that our body strives for regularity
and so whether you have two meals a day
or three meals a day eating meals with
nothing in between is the best thing in
the world for losing weight and for
health so if your friend says hey listen
I only want to eat in this eight hour
period and have a lunch and dinner
that's fine as long as it's regular
alright the thing is when you eat
provided he's in skip for two days
that's not regular hmm
eating less calories will help you lose
weight period that's an amazing
statement I know yes and I can say that
that is factually true what's the one
thing that people can do to be healthier
today I really believe I mean that we
just alluded to is that its regularity
and schedule in between lunch and dinner
if you grab an apple it throws off your
metabolism for two or three days raises
your stress hormones and it's not good
if you grab an apple every day at 2:00
o'clock it's good the key is the
regularity you know when you get hungry
that's your insulin going up and when
your insulin goes up and you don't eat
it stays up and then what happens is you
get less sensitive to it and that's what
type 2 diabetes is so regular schedule 3
meals nothing not a zero in between
that's the best way to lose weight have
optimal health and feel good again maybe
get rid of some of these bad cells in
your husband or put your fork down and
get your butt on the treadmill that also
works are so very effective yes that's a
Gail is being on a treadmill with a fork
is not a safe thing to do